hey you got Frankenstein in my Dorian
Gray and there's coated oil all over my
Bram Stoker hmm maybe just maybe these
great tastes might taste great together
imagine if all of the most famous
characters in fantastic literature met
and mingled under the gas lamps of
Victorian London that's the premise for
the new Showtime series with any
dreadful it's also the exact same setup
as League of Extraordinary Gentlemen but
I'm okay with that
and seriously read the comic that movie
was based on it's great I'm looking
forward to penny dreadful even though
the premise has been done before I love
this kind of metafictional measure
whether it's Wuornos as planetary comics
or the classic Universal horror movies
or the anno Dracula book series not only
did they get to cherry-pick the coolest
elements from different fictional
universes they also dispensed with the
backstory and cut to the chase I mean
did you really need five movies worth of
throat clearing and setup to get to the
team-up of the Avengers I think not do
you know how much space Action Comics
number one devoted to Superman's origin
one panel and that was plenty it's
better to strip-mine familiar literature
for characters or so well known but you
can rely on the audience to already know
what makes them tick and skip to the
good stuff
so Godspeed to penny dreadful and please
don't suck like the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen remember with
great power comes great responsibility
what classic characters would you like
to see on penny dreadful professor
challenger boom get in Little Dorrit let
me know in the comments